oh we got to talk about that that indian
[ __ ] that happened
this was like the biggest [ __ ] story
i don't know why i was promoted so much
but i don't know
like it was did y'all notice this yeah
yeah i was getting shocked how many
people were sending it to me so
tmz did a report like everybody did
report on this i'm like what's going
this is like the industry plant of
stories
yeah you know what i mean like so
basically in india this guy
was gonna marry this woman yep and um
she had a heart attack
yeah died so he married her sister yep
same day
absolutely at the wedding at the wedding
yeah
how do you feel about this this guy's a
king okay i love this guy you know how
much money went into that wedding
yeah this selfish whole gonna die the
day of [ __ ] you can't wait two weeks
you follow her bro i i honestly i hate
this [ __ ] woman
selfish don't don't value money yeah i'm
glad this guy dodged a bullet not
marrying her
i don't know she got no values this girl
she don't hold on to nothing
her sister was about it dawg that's a
soldier also
y'all forget it's probably an arranged
marriage so who the [ __ ] cares really
yeah he probably knew them the same
amount of it's the same genetics you're
marrying the genetics in an arranged
marriage i'm marrying the family yeah
i'm marrying the bloodline biodiversity
same bloodline same biotic
yeah yeah yeah i mean low-key he might
have given that [ __ ] a heart attack to
marry the sister
yo you think the sister was fine i think
if the sister's better look we need to
compare him if the sister is better
looking
you give a girl a heart attack she's 20
who dies from a heart attack 20 years
old
never happened i don't think that's a
real thing that happens i think he
killed him a selfish person herself or
the sister killed
her sister so that she could be the
chosen one we need to look into this
probably he had a wedding gown that day
like oh why do you have a wedding
oh you just happen to fit in that's why
you don't wear white younger maybe she
looks older she's getting a little
desperate
nobody liked her she's like look this is
my chance i gotta plan everything
perfectly kill her the day of the
wedding
india is not wasting those six figures
indian rom-com
that's why you can't wear white to a
wedding because if i see a girl wearing
white at another girl's wedding i'm
assuming there's an assassination
happening wow
yeah why are you so prepared like what's
wrong with you treacherous treacherous
it is kind of crazy but if you look into
your culture it makes sense
oh i can't believe this doesn't happen
all the time in india bro it's a
seven day wedding like yeah but they
marry at like 17. the girl's exhausted
after seven days [ __ ] dancing
non-stop
like i can't believe more women don't
die there wouldn't be oh the heart
attack
yes no they're up until four in the
morning how late are you up the night
before your wedding
i don't think you sleep be honest with
you that's my point bro it's like
burning man
yeah nobody dies burning man that we
know
no we do not cover up bro literally no
look at falci's emails bro watch what
you said about burning man barna now is
that wife when they cremate their dead
burning now so i just think it's
interesting like like
what happens like shorty dies yeah and
everybody already is there
yeah and then [ __ ] die yo
people die riding the train she died
that's what it is no the brother
commented they brought her
dead body into the other room had a team
meeting because they still needed that
dowry
swapped up and had the wedding with the
dead sister in the other room
she got to attend the wedding
after almost
we need to throw a parade for this man
what a noble guy because he saved the
day but so did
she got saved but he saved the day he
said because shorty obviously wasn't
married loser [ __ ]
and then he came through and then i mean
i guess she she hung her games in a
little bit like she was just like
i nominated yeah right she pulled up
right she was with it but he
he didn't even look her down usually
there's like a meeting at least once
before
right he doesn't know who he's meeting
he just
blindly married this woman to save the
day for everybody 20 21 dawg you know
that's extreme
that's like 1956. that's a reality show
b we need to follow that family
yeah didn't your parents meet the day my
dad didn't know he was getting married
until the day of his wedding
neither did this girl say that same
thing yeah i don't see why this is that
crazy
my dad was at another wedding and then
his cousins came up to him
and they were like two cousins were like
scared to tell him they're like
kill him he's like somebody [ __ ] tell
me and they're like you're getting
married today he's getting fitted for
clothes on the way there
this should be happening wait wait he
was at another wedding he's at another
family member's wedding
and then he gets married the same day he
had to leave that wedding to go to his
own wedding get the [ __ ]
that's crazy bruh i'm saying i think
your dad's a hero yeah
yo more than you wouldn't say that if
you saw him the rest of the marriage
but and on that day he was heroic
you kind of undermined my point about
this dude but yeah yeah
that day he was heroic yeah he did what
he needed to do
now do you know about this state where
this happened real quick before we get
into the state we got to talk about how
my man dodged a bullet with this heart
attack lady
yeah because she was going to have
health issues the whole marriage oh my
god
popped up out of nowhere yeah and that
didn't show up in the bio data
if anything he should be upset at her
family because her family knew her heart
wasn't right
where's the wonderlic oh yeah yeah
that's another thing you need to go into
those tests you need to find out we need
to protect testing give us the bride
facts 100
bride facts is perfect because if he did
manage to marry her if she saved that
heart attack
i was the guys a week later he married a
lemon almost she married a [ __ ]
lemon bro
come on and mom what you think dog in
pakistan the same [ __ ] when they're gone
down
why he don't have a money guy
i just want to hear an opinion of a
brown guy because he looking at me well
people at home
he's looking at me like i'm [ __ ] up
so i just need to do some detective
don't throw that [ __ ] on him bro
they got honor killings they would have
killed that [ __ ] for even thinking
about having a heart attack
the second she grabbed their chest no
goats stones
get the stones all right
so what you were going to say this state
yeah it happened in uttar pradesh yeah
that's my state
that's where your people makes the most
sense
nothing ever made more sense to be
honest really
oh we backward dog we be backwards is
that like the country like what is the
uttar pradesh of america alabama
really probably like are you guys
actually it is though
yeah yeah we kind of a punch line if
you're in bombay or whatever
mumbai the comedians will use
they have so we call all of our the in
in like my part of india at least you
call all your older brothers by us
people call us that but like in a
derogatory way
oh like it's like an idiot guy who's
like it's boy yeah yeah i guess so yeah
yeah
it's supposed to be older people but for
some reason they use it to us and it's
i don't mean the status i don't mean the
status is he's like the richest guy in
alabama
prince of alabama bill clinton is from
arkansas what you know about it you know
what i mean you could
you could be nah bro i thought you were
i thought you were royalty
yeah me too like this totally changes
how i feel about you bro like i thought
you were from the bomb ass guys
your dad was a politician or some [ __ ]
you were right about the both of those
things but that don't mean to stay
i'm telling you bill clinton bro what's
this barnyard wedding we're about to go
yo if you were from mumbai you would
have had some elephants in your wedding
bro
yeah yo [ __ ] this utra pradesh wedding
yo
hey ain't nobody want to go to this utra
pradesh wedding
come on bro bruh if you wanna save me
some money don't show up
i'm about to not i'm about to just go to
the [ __ ] zoo instead and get my fix
yo if you see indians at the zoo do you
just pretend it's a wedding
yo real talk why don't y'all just have
the wedding at the zoo the animals are
there already
just bring us all to the bronx zoo start
the wedding
yeah and do it right in front of the
elephant cage or the hippopotamus you
know
enclosure i love this idea this is the
way this is the most indian of weddings
why are you spending a lot of time
moving elephants bro
the elephants are already there yeah
they have a house yo
let's go to ringling brothers you want
to go to barnum and bailey circus
that's why they call it that yeah yeah
exactly they're trained there
so at least you can ride it easily i
mean maybe not you could ride it maybe
to barnum and bailey you would teach me
pretty quickly
probably just subdued animals son i
thought we were going to some
high class yeah i didn't know we going
to a fried chicken wedding bro
hey boy can you believe this [ __ ] wait
but
your girlfriend's not fried chicken wait
yeah that's a good time for the chill
out [ __ ]
i gotta give damian lemon credit for
this he was telling me he called them
fried chicken weddings and that's the
weddings that would be in the apartment
like they would do project weddings but
like the girl would walk down the aisle
in the apartment wow so he would call it
fried chicken
and i'm not going to lie it's kind of
lit romance i know
it's real love i almost got married at
my house seeing that beautiful we're not
putting on airs yeah
damn son we ain't putting on airs either
bro
maybe y'all should we looking for some
bomb ass indian wedding but
what state is your girl's family from i
do know are they from like a nice like a
nice state yeah
they'll they'll have a nicer wedding and
thank y'all for sure okay thank god but
yeah you be [ __ ] bruh in that up that up
it's what it is damn son that's my
people i can't betray my culture by
giving y'all a beautiful wedding
you getting a mid-budget wedding